welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started it's episode nine if
you're scoring at home
uh i am your humble host rich eisen and
it's nfl draft week it's nfl draft week
and when i started this podcast
um i thought to myself you know what i
need to make sure that i differentiate
this show
uh having as many people on to tell
their inspiring
or hopefully inspiring to you uh origin
stories from the world of entertainment
and business and broadcasting um
and i just said you know what sometimes
i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna purposely try and stay
away from my supposed wheelhouse of
sports
um there are some times though where the
guest is just gonna
come from the world of sports and last
week rex chapman was so dynamite and yes
he is from the world of sports although
many people know him now from the world
of social media and what he has built
himself into on that platform uh
on twitter um and also his story
uh if you didn't hear it you gotta go
download it uh because it was
inspiring from the point of view of him
battling addiction
much of his uh adult life
and how he has just gotten started on a
new way of doing things
and um so you need to download that so
rex yes is from
the the world of sports but it is nfl
draft week and
uh on the day that we are dropping if
you will uh wednesdays is when we
are dropping every episode of just
getting started it'll be the day before
the nfl draft and i'll be
sitting in the chair the host chair um
of nfl network for
17th nfl draft and i figured let's get
the origin story of somebody
who uh was drafted in the last round of
his nfl draft
and has not only not only went on to a
uh
decorated career at his position but has
started something new
and just got started on something
that has grown and blossomed into one of
broadcasting's greatest success stories
and what he has become is
something uh to behold with the
millions of his followers every day
across his social media and youtube
platforms
his show on youtube every day from 12 to
3 eastern that does go up against mine
every single day on westwood one and
peacock and odyssey and siriusxm i have
to get the plug-in since
you know he's coming on this show he's
pat mcafee he's highly
uh popular he is hilarious and he is one
of the hardest workers that i know
in this business that is a fact so he's
got a great story to tell about how he
got involved in football
and a great story in how he left
football to get started on his highly
successful broadcasting career
so let's just get started with pat
mcafee
[Applause]
[Music]
there's very few uh people in the
business that uh i get to say
that i uh covered as a national football
league
uh player and then uh have now
um come to say that i'm a competitor
with him and pleased to say both and
that i adore him
and i love everything that he's done
with his career and he
is none other than pat mcafee here on
just getting started how are you pat
rich it's an honor to join you here i
saw that you were starting this up
i saw the big name guests that were out
there just like you started the punters
or people 2 movement
i mean you've always been in my corner
i'm very very thankful for the
opportunity i don't think we're
competitors rich not like we're
competitors at all no you know what pat
uh uh honestly we're on at the same time
and usually in the business
uh from what i've i've i've i've had
people like literally
shut it down just because of that stuff
and i will never i made a promise i
would never be that person
and you what you have done with your
career dude
is i've i've said this to you honestly
i've said this to you many times
off the air and i'll say it here on this
pod it is beyond impressive what you
have done with your career and what you
are doing
and how much bigger you are getting with
each passing day
and you are you're you're an absolute
model to follow in this business it's a
fact
well that seems like that's a bit much
because
it is the people like you the people
like dan
the people that are in the daily sports
grind and have been for a long time who
are the model that i get to follow and i
think
the way people consume their content now
i don't think it matters what time
you're on it's just that you're on and
that you're able to create content
so that's why i don't view you ever as
competition or anybody because i think
the way people consume content now it's
so different
there's enough to go around and
especially i would never want to view
you as competition because you're such a
monster in a game and you've always been
so nice to me which i'm very grateful
for even before anybody knew about me
you've always been very nice so i
appreciate that i do hope more nfl guys
and nba guys and everything
do potentially you know uh do what i
was able to do because there's a lot
more people that have a lot more talent
than i do and
hopefully it's just a chance to showcase
what's what's possible if you just kind
of go for it well the dealers with this
pat is that
it's it's an origin podcast you know and
about where you just got started and
everything like that
and so i i wanted like you were
literally my first choice for nfl draft
week
because out of all the stories that i
have been
able to hear on my show
over the last seven years of doing my
show on the podcast before that you were
on
the the the story you tell about how you
got started
and getting basically on the radar
screen of bill polian
is easily one of my favorite origin
stories that i've been able to have and
i really want to give you the floor
on that for nfl draft week as we are
getting ready
for people to have their dreams realized
in the nfl draft
pat yeah and i think i appreciate that
and obviously you'll do a great job with
the draft coverage and i can't wait to
watch it every single year
there's a lot of dreams that come true
you know and there's people that really
look
forward to draft weekend and draft night
because
you know this is years and years and
years and years of hard work things that
people have never seen happen
in the you know the 5 a.m lifts the
cardio in the morning like
a lot of people's dreams coming true and
everybody just assumes that draft
weekend is a blast for me
it was almost a complete nightmare i i
mean just we're talking
we're talking drunk miserable last day
of the draft
seventh round is just ticking away the
dallas cowboys
told me they were gonna draft me they
draft somebody else
in the fourth round wow i'm sitting on a
golf course with my family waiting for
the call from jerry jones basically
so our day was you know we're golfing
having a blast there's a lot of booze on
the course we'll wait until we get the
call from the cowboys and
we'll just go ahead and turn this thing
up a little bit we knew the first night
i wasn't gonna get drafted second night
i wasn't gonna get drafted so
we obviously celebrated being a cowboy
those first two nights
and then the third day whenever back in
the day whenever it was the third day
for like
i think fourth fifth sixth or seventh or
fifth sixth and seventh or whatever
that was the day that i was gonna get
drafted to be a cowboy so then
while we're on the golf course my mom
who's normally a pretty reserved person
she's in the golf cart and she's waiting
for the party you know and she's the one
that's updating everybody with her phone
and she actually goes uh and i don't
know if you're allowed to use she
actually goes oh
[ __ ] like she she actually says that
right and my mom would never do that
okay so she would not do that she's
she's normally pretty quiet or whatever
so my dad who i think you know pretty
well at this point you've heard about
my dad goes back there and he goes oh no
right and my dad goes oh
cowboy's drafted another guy let's get
out of here so we literally just leave
the golf course
i think we're on like whole 11 or 12
maybe to go back home
and we had no other conversations with
anybody really that told me they were
going to draft me so
like aside from the cowboys i was trying
to figure out what plan b was i wasn't
invited to the combine
uh i i kicked in the senior bowl but
nobody was really talking to me the
cowboys were really the only people
that were talking to me the colts did a
couple workouts but they never told me
like
hey we're gonna draft you or whatever
then when i get drafted
pick 222 via a trade with philadelphia
by that point
our entire house okay the entire
neighborhood drunk
miserable telling stories about how the
good old days when i used to kick for
west virginia
we thought like literally this was over
we thought okay we're completely screwed
at this point
get a call from a 317 number pick 222
i answer uh hello you know and it gets
real
loud it gets real loud and it's it's
bill paulian talking to me
and bill pauline's like hey we just
traded with the eagles uh we can't wait
for you to be a colt and at that point i
think i'm potentially
competing with adam vinatieri for the
kicking position for the kicking
position okay so i'm like
long road ahead of me here i don't know
how this is going to go and then he goes
like we're drafting you to punt
and nobody really they had me work out
as a punter and i thought it was always
like
kick field goals can you also punt if
you have to because in college
we did the rugby rollout punt so i would
just touch the snap
sprint to my right kick as hard as i can
and just hope it would roll
very different than the nfl very
different so nobody was like hey you'll
be a punter so
when bill drafted me goes to punt it was
like uh
almost like oh god and then at that
point the tv had caught up to the news
in the house went from drunken miserable
to lit
and ecstatic we all think i'm going to
kick field goals for
the indianapolis colts they're yelling
the whole house is pumped the whole town
is pumped
and uh bill paulian's assistant
basically goes like uh all right i'm
gonna run through some numbers what
number do you want i'm like what she's
like what number do you want she goes
one's available i was like good good
that's good and she's like okay what
flight
what flight do you want to come out here
next week for the rookie thing she's
like
there's one at like 5 30 a.m or whatever
i'm like that's good it's good like
people are screaming
so it kind of just like came to be a
hell of a party
obviously my entire town of plum uh all
kind of met at this italian joint and we
all just kind of had a
a great time but it wasn't until the
next morning we realized like okay now i
gotta learn how to [ __ ] punt you know
what i mean like
so now like we we celebrated
you know we celebrated it uh but then we
had to make it happen and i was bad for
a long time i was very thankful for bill
paulian who
and i quote said i think you're athletic
enough to figure it out it's like yeah
we're gonna find out if you deserve that
gold jacket or not bill i guess we're
gonna find out so
draft day was insane it was almost
miserable it became a dream come true
but
there's a lot of people out there that
have no clue what's going to happen
draft weekend i love that story man but
i think it's only surpassed by
you putting a tape together back in the
day you put like a resume reel together
to get on the radar screen for colleges
right oh you can give me that mike
tim mcafee so give me that in high
school
i was a soccer player in high school i
was a soccer player okay so i was
pretty good soccer player by the way
like you know like
uh played overseas a few times took some
trips overseas there was
a lot a lot more schools we're talking
like 10 to 12 x
maybe 15x looking at me for soccer
then for football so i always had a
strong leg though the first time i
kicked the football i kicked like a 60
yard field goal or whatever it was like
whenever we were uh we had soccer
practice and there was a kicking camp on
the field right before us
and they were like kicking or whatever
and i was like hey let me see one of
those footballs nerds like like almost
like making fun of the kickers because
in pittsburgh massive football town so i
played a lot of football
never kicked though you know it was like
street football and i played soccer my
entire life was
focused on soccer so i kick a ball it
travels very far and it's a 60-yard
field goal goes through
the guy running the camp he used to kick
in college and he was like hey
hey you should you should think about
doing this you know like i won the punt
passing kick a few years before that
but that's not field goal kicking that's
really just like you got to do what you
got to do and i did it because my mom
kind of forced me to do it so we'd get
some
free tickets to a steelers game because
we couldn't get down to a game or
whatever so i won the national
championship there continue to play
soccer
but then when i started focusing on
taking football nobody really knew
about our high school and football
nobody there's not a lot like it's not a
d1 factory our soccer team good
the football team not so good so we
actually had people that would come to
games and i wouldn't go to practice all
week
i would just walk in like with the fans
on friday so
like that was literally my only
interaction no i barely knew how to put
on the pads like classic movie i didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do with the pads
and then i'd walk in with the fans and
then it was like the locals
would literally watch like oh we got a
big ball kicking guy
for us and he's our soccer player so
people would come watch me
just pound these kickoffs like i would
just hit kickoffs through the end zone
i'd hit field goals i don't think i
missed in high school
and it was just one of these things
where there wasn't a lot of recruiting
that was going on though and my parents
and i had to have a full conversation it
was like
okay so academically life's probably not
gonna work for me right i'm probably
i'm probably not gonna be a doctor okay
uh
probably not gonna be a lawyer that's a
lot of reading probably not gonna get
into that
so if if i really wanted to make
anything which i had dreams of making it
ever since i was a kid
i was very ambitious have been for a
long time um
you know dad a truck driver mama
secretary but i always dreamt of like
you know the big stage whatever it may
be so we had
we had to have a real conversation was
like if you want to get rich playing
soccer you got to go to europe
but if you want to get rich kicking
balls right here in america you can do
that for football and you don't have to
run like nine miles
you know so it's like what do we want to
do here we made a business decision a
lot of things
have to work out obviously for me to
make it to the nfl but i would like to
be a professional
football kicker as opposed to a
professional soccer player because if i
want to get filthy rich that's in
america as opposed to europe
a lot of things are gonna have to happen
but at least we have our mindset right
so my dad
started recording my kicks because
nobody knew i existed really it wasn't
like our high school was out
promoting like oh we got a guy who's 17
years old kicking 70 yard field goals so
it was like my dad put together these
tapes i dropped them off at west
virginia university of pitt
penn state was uh they were sending me
letters with my face
on a uniform they're like oh you're
gonna be a nittany lion you're gonna be
a nittany lion
and then uh mike mcqueary told me i
wasn't penn state material
yes that mike mcqueary told me i wasn't
penn state material
they offered kevin kelly and it wasn't
until like a month before signing day
that i went down to that kicking camp
uh in florida that i got real lucky to
go to
and i kicked like a 65-yard field goal
missed the 70-yard field goal wide right
and the next morning west virginia
offered me and a couple other schools
and
that's kind of all she wrote but my life
is just a series of ridiculously lucky
events
including getting a chance to go on your
podcast way back in the day before they
gave you a daily show
it all kind of leads to each other you
know what i mean rich i do know what you
mean
it really is amazing and then the number
of times that you could give up and you
just say screw it i'm just going to keep
doing it
and doing it and doing it until you
finally get there what would that
conversation
that jerry jones have been like if he
had called you on the golf course
you guys were all lit fourth round no we
weren't lit you were not
we're okay no we're all hungover we're
all incredibly
hungover but we were we were saving you
know we were saving the celebration for
when he called you know whenever hey
listen mcafee i
you know i think we were very pumped up
for we had i was going to be
i was going to be on america's team i
was going to be on america's team it was
a big celebration also in pittsburgh you
know my dad
hated the cowboys so for that like two
days leading up to the draft my dad was
coming around you know like
kid's gonna have a star on his helmet i
guess okay here we go
and then lo and behold i don't get
drafted all hell breaks loose and then
bill pollian showcases his big football
brains and says
hey i want you to play another position
it's going to work out i'm like thank
you bill
thank you bill bully jesus whose job was
it to tell peyton manning that his field
position was in
the hands of a guy who didn't really
punt was a kicker
i mean whose job was that do you think
well peyton manning
you know he's hoping to never see me
anyways like that's kind of
you know and by the way that never
happened there was a couple times i
guess with hunter smith where
he didn't even go on the field to punt i
i had like a couple games with one punt
or whatever because peyton manning's
unbelievable but
as an indianapolis colt punter i'll tell
you this especially with peyton
manning's quarterback
when the offense doesn't get a first
down ain't nobody happy that you're
coming on the field
the fans are booing you peyton's pissed
i mean it is
it is not a desirable you know what i
mean it's not a desirable thing but
the and i think i've told you this story
before uh bill paulian asked me
while we're going through the process i
don't remember if it was yeah it was
bill that asked me
and it was in a call during one of these
workouts or whatever and he it was kind
of just like a throwaway question
that didn't really leave me anything he
was like have you ever held before or
whatever
and i was like all the time you know
because because i kicked in
college so obviously i kicked and punted
so i couldn't have held for myself so
he asked me like have you ever held
before like all the time bill you know
like
love it it's like it's something i enjoy
doing and then i get drafted
and vinatari knew of me because the
uh like the physical trainers and the
athletic training staff
at indianapolis all went to west
virginia so they're all like big west
virginia mountaineers fans so
they knew me vinatieri knew me via them
and vinnie knew that i had kicked in
college so literally
the day after that big celebration i am
very hungover chugging pedialyte trying
to learn how to punt
and i get a call from the goat and he's
like have you ever held before and i was
like
about that uh i have never
i have never i've never held so he sent
me
he sent me to ken walters house ken
walter was his holder in new england
he sent me to ken walters house in north
carolina for like a holding boot camp
that next week
like he was like hey listen just because
you lied you're not ruining my career
but that was something i think
that could have set us off on the wrong
foot and instead it tightened us in the
long run but yeah it was all
all hell broke loose rich it was a
nightmare so just to recap
you thought you'd be drafted in the
fourth round by the cowboys you went all
the way into the seventh
at the very end the uh colts traded to
come get you
you had never really punted much before
at all bill pauline says you're now
our punter and you told him throughout
the whole process that of course you
love holding
you never held and now you're adam
vinatieri's holder and peyton manning's
punter
and that's the way you were born into
the nfl and thus eventually for the
brand
was born through that pat mcafee and and
um just months later kicking off a super
bowl
what an absolute joke dude that's what
i'm saying rich like
my life is so so dumb it makes no sense
i'm very lucky to be
obviously here and doing it but it makes
no sense at all
and by the way peyton and vinnie if it
wasn't for them
i don't think i have the career that i
have either they kind of you know they
were kind of like hey this is how you
got to operate this isn't morgantown
west virginia anymore
okay you're a professional athlete now
and it took me a little bit to learn
there
but i i owe them a lot to get to be
where i was you know
so you got a good uh before you get to
the here and now do you got a good
peyton story good vina terry story a
little bit of both you got one uh
that's your favorite to tell so my my
favorite
my favorite peyton one has been just
overexposed now at this point it's the
red 18 story just because
it was at a casino like payton took me
on this golf trip i was should have
never got invited to go
on you know and then he ends up walking
past me telling me to bet on red 18 and
everybody in the french lick indiana
area
obviously saw peyton walking through the
casino because to get where we were to
his room he had to walk the floor of the
casino
and peyton's not like you know hard to
find
let alone in indiana you know what i
mean so so that was a big moment because
just how the whole casino felt because
of me
with peyton walking by telling me it was
just like uh
that's obviously my favorite moment but
like a vinatary payton story that not a
a lot of people know about is so when
you go to training camp we did training
camp in terre haute indiana
and um they're the engineers i forget
the name of the school yeah it's a small
school i forget it too but i know what
you're talking about
it's just right it's it's left of the
city what's that
uh the engineers it's a really smart
school she my wife is from here she has
no idea what it is either it was
anyways it was a nice school very nice
school there the engineers a lot of very
smart
humans there but that's where we had
training camp it's like an hour and a
half
away from indianapolis and the first
weekend
or second weekend of training camp my
rookie year uh
they said hey everybody's allowed to go
home for a night just come back tomorrow
like
7 30 team meeting or whatever go home so
a lot of people went back to the city
a lot of the rookies went back to the
hotel that we had in indianapolis kind
of take the night off
and i didn't really have anywhere to go
so i just stayed out there
and what i realized was uh payton stayed
adam vinatieri state it felt like all
the og's stayed out there
and we're like yeah we're not going home
for the night or whatever so adam
vinatieri asked me that first weekend
uh he was like so you stuck around i'm
like oh yeah i'm sticking around he's
like cool can you drive me somewhere
later
so they like they asked me to be like
their driver or whatever right yeah
so i drive a car into town there's a
couple
you know adult establishments there it's
like early we're gonna do like uh
not not adult ballets i'm talking like
drinks you know what i mean drinking
yeah i'm talking like drinking places
there's no adults there's no adult
ballets out there but dessert
so anderson university i think is what
it's called anderson no
anderson anderson is anderson's a
different one it's the one before
anderson
franklin college is that what that is
too i don't know no that's in the area
i this is bad i should know this but
anyways
so we go into town and i'm driving them
you know in like
peyton's in the car vinnie's in the car
there's a couple other guys in the car
i'm fresh out of morgantown west
virginia i'm like this is the most
ridiculous
life of all time i don't even know how
to punt yet first week at training camp
by the way rose holmen there you go rose
holman institute of technology there it
is
very good that was lou pellegrino
chiming in via text i didn't mean
interrupt but i just wanted to get that
out of your skull
hey shout out lou not to be confused
with the south harmon institute of
technology
the rose holmen institute of technology
is all engineers
you know it's all engineers a very nice
school but i was only there for one year
training camp but we go into town or
whatever and i'm driving
the car yeah you know that has like
legends in it i'm like what the
what is going on you know so i get there
and
there's like a an area of the bar that's
kind of blocked off because
a couple of the boys are going to go
there you know and peyton's going there
obviously and vinnie's going there
so you know they they wanted to treat
them treat them nice to have a little
night of drinking some beers or whatever
and kind of be relaxed in their own time
so we go up there and i'm sitting like
in the corner at the bar though like i'm
just kind of hanging out letting them do
their thing
and uh vina terry comes over and he's
like what are you doing i'm like i don't
want to you know interrupt whatever you
guys got going on
he's like no no no come over or whatever
like cool so i go over there and they
put a beer in front of me or whatever
okay and put a beer for me i'm like no
no no i'm driving you know what i mean
like i'm not
i'm not you guys gotta do your thing
that's what i'm here for you know and i
thought it was a test
like i thought they were testing me or
whatever and i was like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] this up okay i'm just driving
so they're like no you're not driving
they took the keys they're like hey come
have a good time or whatever so
i used to have a pretty good party trick
where i could chug beers very fast okay
so
like very very very fast like ziggy
zoggy ziggy's on the
oi type fast problem like i used to be
able to delete beers okay not anymore i
had to retire it
but i used to be able to delete beers so
they had this beer right in front of me
and they're like no no you can drink for
real and i kind of like give the keys
over and i'm like is this a tester like
no no no and i just
i just i just make it disappear right
and then
immediately there's a captivated
audience you know it's like oh
dancing monkey here is that real is that
and that's kind of how
like that's kind of how my entire
relationship you know kind of grew i i
feel like
vinnie and payton saw me as like in
others that were there i mean there was
offensive lineman there linebackers all
the ogs the team
that had really been there for like 10
the winningest decade in nfl history
they were all kind of there and i think
that moment was quite an icebreaker
and it was from that moment on where
they were like hey you're okay with us
bud and
they were born for me they didn't know
if i could figure out how to punt but
they were definitely pulling for me and
i'm very very thankful today's episode
of just getting started is sponsored by
geico
do you own or rent your home sure you do
and i bet it can be hard work you know
what's easy
bundling policies with geico geico makes
it easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy it's a good thing too
because you already have so much to do
around your home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save it's geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
[Applause]
well let's get to the here and now um i
remember when you
said you're no longer gonna punt but
you're gonna start
doing uh comedy and also
i guess start what you're doing right
now pat i remember that and i remember a
lot of people thinking
what a lot of people said to me when i
when i left espn to go to nfl network
which is
what the hell are you thinking and
i'm sure you heard that a lot i'm sure
you heard that a hell of a lot
and i'm wondering if um that
process as as the question that i got it
when i joined nfl network it literally
informs me like a brady chip
if you will on my shoulder every day i
do something if that's
if that's the same for you i wonder i
mean
by the way when you went to nfl network
first ever hire i do believe that's true
i mean
you had to know that it was going to be
successful i mean you know the nfl they
had to have now who what stooges were
telling you that was a bad move
hey by the way you were legendary on
sportscenter though too so i can
understand
how that is something that happens no i
mean again and if
well it was an educated guess let's put
it that way like if the nfl is going to
say we're going to start our own network
and all 32 teams are popping in a nice
chunk of change to get this thing
launched
we were only on a directv and small
cable we were on in like 11 12 million
households
going from espn nfl network i sliced to
use a phrase that used
before i sliced my platform by 10x
like right off wow i do not know that
i'm doing sportscenter with stuart scott
in front of 100 million people and then
now i'm doing nfl total access
on on a network that was only in 10
million homes
that's it boom wow i did not know that
that was the way that people looked at
that oh yeah
by the way hey hey rich yeah hey
thank you for making that leap we love
nfl network thank you no
but it's it i'll tell this story this is
a great story
so you know my wife was in southern
california before we moved out here
because that's where nfl network was
because she was covering you want to
talk about you know uh
right place right time too she was
covering la sports when reggie bush was
at usc and shaq and kobe
were winning championships and the
angels won the world series so she was
locked into los angeles and the first uh
you know winter we were here in o4
because nfl network started in o3
she had us going to every single nba
all-star game party
somebody comes up to me says i watch you
every day i'm like really
you got nfl network because we were only
on in 10 million homes
guy says to me no i'm talking about
sportscenter
he goes what are you talking about i'm
like i'm on nfl network now like you're
not on espn anymore
pause and he leans into me says are you
all right
like yes like he asked me are you okay
and i'm like if you got
a [ __ ] mirror i'll fog it up for you
if you want you know like i'm more than
happy to do that you know
i tried not to get all uptight but yeah
so i was hearing a lot about i went on
jimmy i went on kimmel's show to promote
it
and he told me on his show in front of
the whole
abc network audience that i would be
back on sportscenter in six months
wow you know and it's a funny late night
moment and i know he's just being
you know he he's a sweetheart of a guy
and it wasn't being
rude but it kind of sticks
you know what i mean it sticks hey i'm
happy you made that leap
i'm happy the nfl network is what it is
and uh
yeah i think i think you could obviously
assume that i had
uh similar type situations when even my
mom and dad a couple of times there was
a couple like are we
are we 100 sure i'm like i think so i i
think so i think it's the right time
why were you so sure why were you sure
about that so
i got a chance you know to kind of
experience the
off the field stuff that was happening
while i was playing towards the end of
my career
um i had a podcast i'd launched whenever
i was playing
i had done a stand-up comedy tour while
i was playing i had a merch business
while i was playing i had pretty good
social media
stuff whenever i was playing so in in
the stand-up comedy i rented out the
theaters and sold the tickets myself
on my twitter account like so like
everything i did i
i was kind of doing it myself took a lot
of lumps but i also got a chance to see
that
there's a there's a world outside of the
nfl that is currently blossoming which
is the
uh the internet you know it's the modern
day gold rush or whatever even more so
then
whenever i was going so i just with
another knee surgery
i wasn't necessarily loved by the regime
you know
that was kind of there at the end so i
didn't necessarily love going into work
anymore
i was really enjoying and getting
fulfillment out of what i was doing off
the field
whether it was all that [ __ ] or the
foundation stuff that i got to do it was
just
i had taken care of everybody already
financially in my circle i'd gotten
everybody back
you know to zero or you know in the
green as opposed out of debt i feel like
i hit the reset button for a lot of
people it just
and with the opportunity i was going to
create my own app
because i had a pretty loyal fan base in
indiana and parts of the midwest that
would
you know rock with me with whatever i
mean the first time i went on stage it
was in front of like 2 800 people or
whatever the ticket sold out in six
seconds
so it was like i had a really loyal crew
of people that
were following me and i'm so so lucky
for that i have no idea why i think
they enjoy seeing the idiot do things
but i appreciate the hell of him so
i i just felt like retiring i was i was
going to retire a year before i did
chuck and i took a trip to japan uh for
uso and we kind of had
you know in a 17-hour flight you have
some conversations i come back and then
i just had the same feeling again and i
was going to start my own app and i was
going to charge like a monthly
subscription like a buck buck 99 and i
was doing the math on how many people i
thought
would potentially get that and then
portnoy and erica heard about that over
at bar stool
and dave reach out to me and dave has
been somebody that's obviously utilized
the internet as a business and kind of
set the staple of how
to kind of run an internet business
alongside rogan
and a few others have really uh done it
well and he said
he said you know i hear what you want to
do or whatever let us just kind of help
you through this process kind of educate
you a little bit on how the internet
works a little bit more and
i didn't want to move to new york i
stayed in indianapolis or my own thing
and then
when it came time to kind of separate i
feel like you know i kind of went
through a quick
ivy league school of how to work the
business plus with my own experience it
was just
the timing felt 100 right for me and
whenever when i
chose to retire and there was a lot of
people talking you know wilbon there's
that infamous clip where will
basically saying i have no friends
because my friends should be
holding my uniform on me and forcing me
back i just made a pro bowl so i
appreciate the
amount of respect everybody had for me
but i didn't even want to
i didn't want to pick up a football
after i retired i didn't want to look at
a field
for like six months to a year because i
wanted people to know that like
i made the decision with conviction i
feel like i can be successful here
to your point if i'm not successful here
everybody's here is gonna say i'm an
idiot i shouldn't retire and i wasted
years
so i got real stubborn i got real
stubborn on making this work
uh grinding out as much as i could
alongside my team
and uh yeah it's just like it's nice to
go out and kick a ball every once in a
while
knowing that it's not just uh i'm gonna
definitely go back it's just like i
enjoy doing it now so it's uh
it's been a cool ride for sure but the
kobe chips on the shoulder is definitely
a real thing in everything that i do
there's no question about it pat and
i'll say this you know as we
we roman you know just linger in this a
bit and then
just uh and then we'll we'll wrap it up
with you here um
i i'm i'm serious when i say this like
my
my show uh went through a lot of changes
this past year and that's what a lot of
this podcast is about i've been sharing
a lot of these stories and all
you know and i you know uh when i saw
you
at the combine in 2020 when i appeared
on your show
um you know and i was wondering what the
hell
was i gonna do without the
the network you know at t that was
owning my show for all that time and
they informed me two days before
christmas that dan patrick and i would
have to find a new home
and i was wondering what what i was
going to do and
um you know who i reached out to
i reached out to you and i saw your
honor i know i saw your operation
firsthand and i just kind of want
everyone to know this
because you make it look easy you're
funny you know
and you show up in your tank tops which
you know i'll never be able to do
and you stand there with your baseball
bat and you have conversations with your
boys that
mimic and are something that you know
normal regular people have and it's also
aspirational where regular people
want to be part of your world okay they
want to laugh with you and it's really
natural but it is a [ __ ] ton
of hard work what you're doing the fact
that you add the wwe on it and i know
that you're you know you're jumping top
rope and you're having fun but that's
work
i mean no no seriously you're you're
you're working your ass off
and your audience is following you and
this is a serious
business that you've grown and that's a
fact
you know and i'm um it's it's a true
fact and
i don't know man you got a ton of energy
i mean i know you did three hours and
then you're pod and now you're talking
to me right now
god bless you i mean it's a serious
reserve that you have pat that's a fact
well i appreciate that rich that means a
lot and
when i got you know really schooled to
the game of the internet i think after i
retired
and i realized like oh i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be working like
you know back to the number probably 10x
what i would do if i was in the nfl but
getting a chance to do it with my boys
you know my team
getting a chance to kind of live out
these incredible opportunities like
working with the wwe i mean
i main event at a wwe pay-per-view and
that is just
outrageous it was in the middle of
football season it was just an
opportunity that
if i don't do i got to be the dumbest
human of all time but
when i was in the nfl and i and i talked
about getting a chance to do a lot of
things
the bob and tom show which is a morning
radio show that's been syndicated
across america on fm am channels for
like 30 some years at this point
they allowed me to come in and kind of
watch the way they operate
and being successful as a radio show for
that long especially with a group of
people who
you know especially at the wake up at 3
30 in the morning and everything like
that
it was very cool to learn from them tom
griswold told me something
tom griswold told me something hilarious
and it was one morning
i forget somebody was given an answer
about something and i like
well you got a feel for him or whatever
and then like kind of moved on during a
commercial break tom looked to me and he
goes
he goes hey pat just something to think
about he said the people that listen to
the show
and he wasn't talking about me he was
talking about somebody else to talk the
people that listen to the show
they got enough [ __ ] they got enough
[ __ ] going on
all right just entertain them and just
keep it moving like that is
that is what we do that is what we're
trying to do we're trying to be a mental
vacation
so the thought of you know ever saying
no
or ever being down or not being like
full go
like that has never crossed my mind
because it's like if people spend their
time watching or listening to our [ __ ]
like i want them to know
i'm going all in like i am all in every
single time
i will say i'm gonna get burned out at
some point
but i enjoy everything i do right now so
i assume i assume that that crash will
come rich and i appreciate
i appreciate the shout out for the hard
work but i enjoy everything right now so
so much
yeah and the wwe that that seems like a
natural
fit for you and a natural extension for
you and it's
the zenith of pop culture popularity
right now and
you know i think it dovetails into your
audience and your audience into that i
mean it is kind of a natural
that you're doing you you must be
pinching yourself
doing that certainly now for fox on
friday nights pat
yeah it's insane you know i'm sitting
next to michael cole
i got vince mcmahon dropping into my ear
via headset like an actual
voice of god what do you mean what's it
he's getting yeah so when you
yes when you're a commentator with the
wwe since you know it's vince mcmahon's
company and
vince mcmahon used to be a commentator
and he's still hands-on with everything
like if something changes with the show
or something he'll come in and say like
to the commentators who are telling the
story you know the commentator's job
there's a real job to the commentating
in michael cole
is unbelievable at what he does syracuse
grad
he is an unbelievable talent of what he
does because he has to direct and call
and everything like that
but yeah this past friday night
smackdown was my first time with vince
mcmahon in the building
and all of a sudden out of nowhere just
boom voice of gods in there and i like
sat up and i'm like oh my god here we go
but like i get a chance to hear a
billionaire's brain
spill through his mouth into my ear wow
talking about his product that he
created that has become a global
phenomenon it was just it was one of
those moments where i'm like this is the
dumbest life of all time
i should not be here but let's enjoy the
ride while we have it you know it's just
really cool stuff rich and i can't say
this enough i cannot say it's enough i
said it earlier you laughed it off
when you invited me to do the rich eisen
podcast i flew out to l.a strictly for
that i thought it was the coolest thing
of all time i was so thankful for the
opportunity you've been
a massive part of everything i've done
for the long haul and i appreciate the
hell out of you
all right right back at you pat i always
you you you had me at hello
literally and then when you know i i had
i had my show
and that i started seven years ago and
then you'd come out and do an hour
and i would see your popularity based on
the responses that i would get from my
audience as well
and obviously you're doing it every day
on your youtube stream and everything
else
outside of all that and i did see uh the
other day
you uh talking about um i guess and
we'll finish this up
a snub uh an emmy award snub for the pat
mcafee show and you
um you know i saw that rich i saw that
rich you know like dan patrick oh gee
you know you og in there good morning
football i love good morning football
okay sportscenter's been around a long
time there's a couple daily shows though
that i think like you know i'm going
three and a half hours every single day
my boys at least deserve a little bit of
a nod here i think we
you know in our stats and analytics on
the back end of youtube we could show
and say hey we're doing something but
what we did learn is you gotta you gotta
uh
you gotta nominate yourself yes you have
to put a real impact
did you know that no no no absolutely
not we didn't even know
we did not even know that these sports
emmys existed uh rich so
says pat yeah it's our fault it's our
fun this is one of those things
yeah yeah this is one of those things
whenever you're you know you're
independent in
indiana you can get miss out on some
things you know so
we were a little bit upset with some
people we should have been upset with it
is our fault but
it's each their own it's another day
it's another day rich live and learn
yeah you've got it you have to
put in a submission um yeah for it they
don't just come
find you um despite your immense
popularity pat you still have no no no
no
we just thought maybe there was you know
a couple overlords that are just
watching everything making these
decisions and then
the news was broken to us that you know
no no you have to you have to actually
they actually you know somebody actually
reached out to us and was like
can you put together a four-year
consideration maybe for this one it's
like sorry
we don't know the biz we don't know the
business well here's what you also have
to do pat
and this will be in a way just uh my my
latest um
you know thank you for doing this then
the ultimate you're welcome
on this process is that the way this
works is
you put in a submission and the people
who watch it
are all supplied by the networks
okay now you're not supposed to be able
to review
anything that involves your network but
you kind of pack the court in a way so
you've got to put a submission in and
then you've got to have some of your
staff
review other people's material and
then you get part of the system
and boom the pat mcafee show becomes
emmy nominated
and so does pat mcafee for host and then
you show up
hopefully post pandemic and totally
wreck the place like you did at the
draft and announcing the colts pick and
just
rule the universe and make your mark
that way pat in making an acceptance
speech
for the generations to behold that's the
plan
that's the master plan it seems like
that's a lot of work
okay seems like that's a lot of work
we'll get to that but i think what we
landed on
before knowing that we had to
potentially
nominate ourselves is i'm just gonna go
to that uh bald dude from pawn stars and
just buy one
i'm just gonna buy one and just say you
know what we earned it we did it
and uh just kind of move on i'm thinking
about doing that with a super bowl ring
since drew brees and his dumb baby
you know won that game uh my rookie here
so
you know if you can't earn it buy it you
got to do what you got to do rich
pat it's called growing it's called
growing and obviously you just keep
growing and
uh i really appreciate you coming on
this pod man you're uh
you're like i said one of my favorites
and anytime i know we want to do a home
and home uh for the show once i get my
my visual technology up and running
we'll do it we'll do it
we gotta figure that out we gotta figure
out how to do that in here there has to
be a way that we could facetime each
other and be live at the same time has
any show done that has any show done
like a home and home at the same time
i think we i think we got to do it does
that mean like aj hawk i gotta smoke a
cigar
during the conversation because that i
don't know if that would really work
for me but we could just hey his
ventilator broke today his uh
his uh his fan broke today he had
actually started whistling
because he blows 10 cigars through that
thing it's
i've never seen anything like it have
you ever seen somebody smoke that many
cigars in your life
i don't think i ever had it's
unbelievable hey but don't mess with the
system
don't mess it you bring your own device
by the way whatever you need you can you
can do that for ours
and uh hopefully we don't ruin your show
we got to remember fcc on your show
right yeah
pretty much i think so yeah we're on
terrestrial yeah we'll remember that
we'll we'll have to remind everybody
we should do that well i'd love to i
would absolutely love it
thanks for doing this though pat i
really appreciate it brother
thank you man what's the name of this
thing the beginning i'm just getting
started
right there that's i even got like a
little bit of a
piece of wood right there it's called
branding oh is that it's pretty
paddle or it's a pillow yeah it's a
paddle
is it because you're paddling the
competition that is correct i just take
everybody's competition and just like
take that rome you know like just that's
the way i do it
you know that's the way i roll hilarious
you're the man pat
mcafee show every day on uh the uh
highly popular youtube stream for pat
mcafee 12 to 3 eastern what wwe
friday nights on fox and your podcast
network and
uh congrats on everything bud appreciate
it yeah and i appreciate you plugging it
but to be honest it's not worth it
listen to rich's stuff
rich eisen is live every day on peacock
and westwood radio stations across the
country
that's where i would spend my time if i
were you but i appreciate the time here
invading people's brains that have
probably never heard of pat mcafee
everybody here on just getting started
man i love pat he just only knows one
speed and
it is just uh it is just so much fun he
is so funny
he is so funny and people just flock to
his uh style of broadcasting
and um i'm glad that he joined us on
this draft week where so many
uh so many stars are born and so many
careers are started and so many
careers that people think are going to
get started the way that they hoped
would get started
aren't started that way and they have to
be a self-starter
because they're free agents and pat was
almost an undrafted free agent we all
know what opportunities came his way
with indianapolis and what he's he's
made of them and i'm serious i'll just
tell you again
um because i share as much as i possibly
can here on this show and i got to meet
pat
through my punters or people 2 campaign
i'm wearing the t-shirt that i had made
up through
through my my show merchandise store um
and um you know that that show
merchandise store that this was in was
was through directv and at t
um who supported my show uh helped
birth it in 2014 and then i got a call
two days before christmas in 2019 to say
that their
uh the audience channel was going to be
shuttered and
my show along with dan patrick's that
had been on audience for
all those years dan's been on audience
much longer than mine
uh would have to find new homes and that
everything was moving to
their streamer that at t was owning and
operating hbo max and hbo max didn't
have a live portal and even if they did
they didn't think that
my show would fit their business model
and i had to go
find a new home for it and the clock was
ticking
the clock was ticking and my my my my
show
that i put so much sweat equity into
um was on life support and the pandemic
was about to hit and i'm
in indianapolis for the combine and i
saw what pat was doing with youtube and
i knew that was going to be my first
home
uh once that i got home from the combine
is when my
my time with audience and the audience
network was over i said
farewell i signed off of audience
network before i took that flight to the
combine in indianapolis in 2020
and i knew i would have to go on youtube
and i knew pat knew the
the medium well i went on pat's show at
the combine because he's he emanates
from his own studio in indianapolis and
i saw his operation
and i said walk me through how it works
with youtube how does it work
what do you do to game the system how do
you get your algorithm up
what are the ins and outs of making this
a successful business and he shared it
all with me
he shared it all and again i know the
guy that you see on the air
uh the guy that you you see and you know
talk in very plain language you see the
guy that wears his
tank top and is you know it's standing
up with his microphone holding a bat
holding a hockey stick doesn't look
traditional and it's not traditional
media
but what the guy does is he works his
ass off talking three hours a day
growing a business talking to
subscribers talking
talking to distribute distribution
partners to make it bigger talking
advertisers
talking to people who want to tap into
his world
and i reached out to him and he gave me
some two cents and i went from
youtube beginner to growing it and
reaching out to nbc sports and getting a
deal with them and nbc sn for just the
spring and the summer and then went from
there to peacock and went from there to
where i am today partners with westwood
one partners with siriusxm partners with
odyssey
um my first free streaming
audio partner that just started this
week
growing it and um you know where i was
one year ago at this time getting ready
for an nfl draft
which i hosted digitally for their nfl
draft-a-thon
from this chair from this seat that i am
currently
doing just getting started wondering
where my show was going to go
wondering what was going to happen with
my show with
with the sports world we were in the
middle of a walk down
commissioner roger goodell was doing his
draft conducting his role in the nfl
draft from
his basement from his barker lounger
sitting there with his feet up calling
out picks
me wondering what the hell the football
season was going to look like and where
my show might be going
it was um it was some wild times and i
did reach out to pat for some help
and you could see what he's doing it's
something i highly respect
and i wanted to bring his story to you
here on just getting started if you are
thinking about
hey i've got an idea i'm going to leave
my job or i feel like i'm not too happy
with anymore and i believe in a certain
concept that i have and it's not a
traditional idea if you are out there
thinking maybe you could start your own
show there's youtube there's so many
different ways for you to start it
and you know obviously pat had a
successful career
that uh feathered his nest a little bit
but
he also believed himself
and just got started on something new
and i wanted him to tell his stories and
i knew some of them would just be laugh
out loud hilarious so
that's it for this ninth episode of just
getting started we'll reach double
digits
and we've got a lot of great fun guests
in the hopper that uh that are
soon to be scheduled we'll keep uh keep
uh you up to speed on all that and just
uh
do us a favor tell everyone about the
pod subscribe
to it if you already haven't hit us with
a five star rating that will be
wonderful too
signing off on this latest episode of
just getting started with pat mcafee
you